l'ét c'est une visite du cœur
déclaration de Jacques Chirac avant
d'arriver au Maroc tout à l'heure une
visite d'État de 3 jours la première
depuis l'avènement du jeune roi Mohamed
VI une quinzaine de chefs d'entreprise
sont aussi du voyage Jean-Marc hous
abdelzou sur place un bfou plutôt
sportif sous le soleil féroce qui
accueillit aujourd'hui à fè capitale
spirituelle du Maroc la première visite
d'État de Jacques Chirak depuis
l'accession sur le trône de Mohamed
VI la France au côté du Maroc à un
tournant délicat de l'histoire d'un
royaume chérifien encore traumatisé par
les 45 morts de l'Atlanta islamiste du
16 mai dernier un soutien réaffirmé non
seulement à la monarchie
constitutionnelle mais aussi un pays
musulman modéré tourné vers l'Europe où
il faut désormais compter avec le poids
du vote
islamiste question d'amitié question
d'intérêt la France est le premier
partenaire économique du Maroc et son
premier fournisseur d'aide au
développement c'est au Maroc que se joue
une partie décisive pour l'avenir de la
paix en Méditerranée Derris ces F
officiel la volonté personnel de Jacques
Chirac d'afficher son soutien politique
et économique à Mohamed 6 et un Maroc
fragile où la pauvreté le terrorisme
menace toujours les premiers pas de la
démocratie